-Our next guest is
a talented actress
you know from films such as
"Mad Max: Fury Road"
and "Magic Mike"
and shows like
"The Girlfriend Experience"
and "The Terminal List."
She stars in
"Daisy Jones & The Six,"
which begins streaming
on Prime Video this Friday.
Let's take a look.
-What can I do for you?
-I don't know.
-What do you want?
-I want to make a record.
-Okay.
-And I want people
to listen to it over and over
again until it breaks.
And then I want to make
another one.
-Well, you got one great song.
All we need now is 10 more.
-Give me a week.
-[Bleep ]
♪♪
-Oh, and, Daisy,
this is now the worst song
on your album.
♪♪
-Please welcome back to the show
Riley Keough, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
Welcome back!
-Thank you!
I just grabbed your hand.
I didn't know if you were
offering or introducing.
-It was like,
"And this is the couch."
I did. I did want you to --
I wanted you to use it
as you saw fit.
-Thank you.
-Yeah.
I think it went
very smoothly.
It's a little awkward how much
we're talking about it now,
but...
-"Stop."
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, so this is -- because
this is a show about a band,
and also there's an album
that has come out.
It must be so different than any
other show you're promoting,
because it does also feel like
you're promoting as a musician.
-Totally. It's the first time
I've done anything musical.
That's been its own experience.
But we had our album
come out today.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's wonderful, too.
Obviously you have --
you come from a musical family,
but I'm surprised that you've
never done anything musical.
-Yeah, I mean, I played, like,
a little bit of piano
when I was a kid and
played around with it.
But I just never was interested.
-That's so funny.
-I know. I love it now.
You know?
-So did -- I mean --
Did the casting process sort of
have to take a leap of faith
that you were gonna eventually
be able to figure it out?
-Yes.
I think that I oversold myself
a little bit in the beginning
of the process.
-That's very nice that
you're admitting it now, yeah.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
No, I -- it was something
I just really wanted to prove
to myself that I could do,
I think, ultimately, and
I think they saw that in me
and they wanted
to give me a chance.
[ Laughter ]
-But you did take it seriously.
And I hope --
Is it correct to say
that you and your cast
went to a band camp of sorts?
-Yeah.
Band camp, we would start it
at like 9:00 in the morning.
We would do singing lessons
and guitar lessons
and piano lessons
and full band practice
and go over to the other side,
at Sound City Studios in L.A.
and, like, record our album.
So it was like a full, like,
Rock -- School of Rock.
-Were other cast members maybe
a little bit farther along
in their education than you?
Or did you --
-Yes.
-Okay, got it.
-Everyone in our band
was a musician,
other than Sam and myself,
who are the two lead singers.
So it was, like --
[ Laughter ]
It was, like, crazy.
But it was --
What was amazing is the first --
the first time
we ever rehearsed together,
I was super nervous.
Because we'd been --
we'd been practicing alone
and getting our lessons
by ourselves.
And I was thinking, you know,
like, I'm the worst one here.
And then I met Sam.
[ Laughter ]
No, and then we had our first
singing lesson together.
And there was this moment where
we were looking at each other,
and they kind of, like,
wanted us to sing
really close
to each other's face
and, like, build chemistry,
the first time
we'd ever met each other.
And we both realized, "Oh,
we're both, like, awful."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And from then on, I just felt,
like, super grateful to have --
that we were both kind of
starting from the bottom.
-When you meet -- again,
I think
a lot of romance starts
when you meet someone
as awful as you are.
-Right? Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, then you finished --
I guess there's this conclusion
of band camp.
At some point,
you have to move on
and start doing the show.
-Yeah.
-And I heard you had
a concert of sorts
for friends and family?
-We did.
There was no friends or family.
It was very --
It was a lot of executives.
-Okay. So the people...
[ Laughter ]
-I think --
-They're like,
"Please call us
'friends and family.'"
-I think they wanted it to feel
like friends or family.
We walked in the room, and it
was just, like, a corporate...
-How many people would you say
were there in your audience
for your concert?
-I think I blacked out.
But it might have been, like --
I feel like
I've said that
in every interview.
People think I have
a drinking problem.
[ Laughter ]
It must have been like --
I want to say it was 50, 60.
-Oh, that's a real audience,
yeah.
-You know, it was --
It was -- Yeah.
-It does seem like at least one
thing you have going for you is,
again, because this is a cast
where you also play a band --
-I want to hear the one thing.
-You have one thing.
No, but it just seems like
you guys
feel like a very close cast.
-We are.
-I see photos of
you guys doing press.
And I don't know,
maybe it's because
you are playing people
in a band together,
but you actually look like you
have a nice group chemistry.
-We do.
And I think that's, you know,
been the most special thing
about the show is
that all of us are, you know --
it's not often
you get to do a series
with 10 people your age.
-Yeah.
-And all get along well.
And I think that that sort of
translates into the show.
And that's been,
you know, authentic.
-This is a show
about a band
and what a band goes through.
You obviously have
a career as an actor.
Do you -- Is there anything
about band life
that feels more alluring
to you now that you wish --
-100%.
-Okay.
-The -- I realized,
in making this show
and recording the album
that, like, our actors' job
is very, like,
serious and stressful,
and they're very laid-back
and very easy-going.
I remember going
into the studio,
and we're always, like,
"Got to be on time,
got to be punctual,"
and everyone's late.
And I go to --
And then, you know --
And it's -- to them, it's not.
It's like 15 minutes.
To me, coming from film,
I'm like, "Oh, my God,
it's a disaster."
-Right.
-You know?
[ Laughter ]
And, like, we get in the studio,
and I remember
being like, "Okay,
what time's lunch?"
And they were like, I mean,
"Whenever you're hungry."
And I was like, "Aah!"
[ Laughter ]
I think I need, like, structure.
But then I, like,
relaxed into it.
And I was like,
"This is so much cooler."
-That's great.
-Yeah.
-I don't know why you ran
from it when you were a kid.
-I know.
-Well, that's alright.
It's very nice that you
found your way back to it.
-I did.
-So, I know
you met your husband on set.
-Yeah.
-You guys were working
on "Mad Max" together.
And then he has a cameo
in this show.
-He sure does.
-Now, tell us --
This Is a wonderful story
how this cameo came about.
-Well, the cameo came about
[Chuckles]
because I have to have
intercourse...
-Uh-huh?
-...with a random person
in the show.
-Yeah.
-And the producers were like,
"It would be so funny
if it was your husband."
-That's so nice.
[ Laughter ]
And so he agrees?
-Yeah.
-Now, though, you're on set
with your husband,
you know,
simulating intercourse.
Was that more or less awkward?
-It was more awkward.
-Yeah, I bet.
-It sounds good
in the beginning,
but as I think about it --
-I think that they were thinking
it would be less awkward,
and then I --
and then we got there
and like, "This is
really uncomfortable."
-Yeah.
-I mean, you don't --
like, for one,
I've never had pretend sex
with my husband.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
That's true.
-You know?
And for two, you know --
normally, typically,
when you do these things,
and it's, like,
somebody coming in for the day,
you're like, "Hello.
Nice to meet you," and
you kind of
get down to business,
and it's very professional.
But with him,
it was just like, really,
like we were just giggling
the whole time.
-Yeah.
-I would be so worried
if I had to have pretend sex
with my wife
in front of a bunch of people.
She'd be like,
"He doesn't usually..."
[ Laughter ]
-That's what was --
-"He's putting
a lot more attention..."
[ Laughter ]
-That's what happened.
Because we were --
In this scene --
and this is a spoiler alert --
in the scene, it's not --
it's not like --
I'm not really enjoying it.
-Yeah.
-And I feel like
I really kept feeling inclined
to be like, "In real life..."
[ Laughter ]
"...it's not like this."
And I was like, "I'll just
keep that to myself."
-Yeah.
-That's good that you guys
found together
that when you have real sex,
it should be with him,
and pretend sex
should be with strangers.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
That's a very helpful message
to all married couples.
-It was, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You also directed a film...
-Yeah.
-...I guess, last year now.
-Mm-hmm.
-"War Pony" which you worked on
for a great long time, I know.
-Yeah.
-This is a real process.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-And it was at
the Cannes Film Festival.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Did you enjoy directing?
Is that something you think
you'll do again?
-I -- "Enjoy" is
an interesting word.
[ Laughter ]
It was wild.
-By the way,
I like how honest
this answer is.
-You're my last interview
of the week.
And I'm just really
letting It all out.
-You're going to be honest.
-Just, like...
[ Laughter ]
-I [Laughs] -- I, um --
I did enjoy it. It's wild.
It's, like,
much more challenging than I --
I think actors have this feeling
that they can just,
like, direct.
-Yeah.
-And it's really hard.
-It is.
I mean, I think
that you forget how exhausting
decision-making is.
-Yes.
-Because, ultimately, I think
every role on a film set
is tiring in its own way.
-Yeah.
-But I think the amount of --
even just tiny decisions
you have to make as a director,
people always underestimate.
-Totally.
Decisions, and then just, like,
the admin and the scheduling
and just things that I'm totally
not interested in,
you know, that you have to do.
-[ Chuckles ]
-But it was amazing. You know?
And we were able to make
this very collaborative
film experience
that was, you know --
I'll remember it
for the rest of my life.
-Well, congratulations on that.
-Thank you.
-Congratulations on the show.
-You're discovering
your musical talent.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-It's really lovely
to have you here again.
You guys, that's Riley Keough.
"Daisy Jones & The Six" begins
streaming on Prime this Friday.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."